NARRATOR: The following
content provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is the
second 086 lecture and it'll be
my second and last lecture on
solving ordinary differential
equations -- u prime
equal f of u and t.
So last time, we got Euler's
method, both ordinary,
forward Euler, which is this
method for the particular
equation -- so I'm using my
model problem, as always,
u prime equal a*u.
That's the model.
And I'm using small u for
the true solution and capital
U for the approximation.
By whatever method we use,
and right now, that method
is forward Euler.
We looked at the
idea of stability,
but now let me
follow up right away
with the point of stability.
Where does stability come in?
So I want to do that for
this simplest of all methods,
because you'll see how we
get to an error equation
and we'll get to a similar
error equation for much
better methods.
So the accuracy of
Euler is minimal,
but the question of
how stability enters
and how we show
that it converges
will be the same, also in
partial differential equations,
so this is the place to see it.
So I'll start with that, but
then after that topic will
come better methods than
Euler and the first step
will be, of course,
second-order methods,
because Euler and backward
Euler are only first-order.
And we'll see -- actually,
that'll be the point.
Not only will show
when they converge,
why they converge, but also
how fast they converge.
What's the error?
This estimate of the
error is something
that every code is going
to somehow use internally
to control the
step size delta t.
So I'm just going to go
with the model problem,
u prime equal a*u,
the Euler method.
So here is the evaluation
-- a*u is f there,
so it's really delta
t multiplying f,
which is just a*u
in this easy case.
Here's the true
solution and then
here is the new point, that
when I plug the true solution
in to the difference
equation, it, of course,
doesn't satisfy exactly.
There's some error term -- this,
I would call the discretization
error -- making the
problem discrete.
So this is the, you could say,
the error at a single time step
-- it's the new error that's
introduced at time step n.
Error, now, is going to be
-- e will be u, the true one,
minus the approximate, so I
just subtract to get an equation
for the error at
time step n plus 1.
That subtraction
gives e_n, a delta t.
That subtraction gives e_n, and
this is the inhomogeneous term,
you could say, the new error.
So the question is -- first, the
question is, what size is that,
the local error?
Then the key question is, when I
combine all these local errors,
what's the global error?
So first, the local error.
You can see what this
is, approximately,
because the true solution would
be e to the a*t and we all know
that e to the a*t times
u_0 -- e to the at --
there's a 1 plus an a delta
-- from a single time step --
sorry, I should have said the
true solution would grow by e
to the a delta t over one step.
It would multiply by
e to the a delta t,
but instead of multiplying
by that exponential e
to the a delta t, we're only
multiplying by the first two
terms in the series.
So the error here is going to
be something like a half delta t
squared -- that's the key point
where we see the local error --
times probably a squared --
we needed an a squared and u.
So a squared u_n,
that would really
be the second derivative.
I'll put it in as
second derivative,
because that's what it would
look like in a nonlinear case.
So I'm working the linear
case for simplicity,
but the point is that this
is the Euler local error.
That's so typical,
that you really
want to look at that local
error, see what it looks like.
There is some constant and
that has a certain effect
on the quality of the method.
There's a power of delta
t and the question,
what is that exponent
has a big effect.
So that exponent is
the order plus 1.
So for me, Euler's method
has accuracy p equal 1.
Over a single delta t step,
the error is delta t squared,
but we'll see that when I
take 1 over delta t steps
to get somewhere, to get
to some fixed time like 1,
then I have one over
delta t of these things
and the 2 comes back down to
the 1, which I expect for Euler.
And finally, this term is out
of our control, basically.
That's coming from the
differential equation.
That would tell us how
hard or easy the method
is, the equation is.
So if u double
prime is real big,
we're going to expect to have
to reduce delta t to keep this
error under control, so
that's a typical term --
a constant delta t to a power
of p plus 1 and the p plus first
derivative, the second
derivative matching that 2
of the solution.
So that's -- if
I now put this --
think of that as here in the
-- as the sort of inhomogeneous
term or the new source term.
I just want to estimate e_n now.
So I've done the local
part and now I'm interested
in putting it all together.
How do I look at e -- so
I really want, somehow,
the solution -- e at some
definite time n is what?
I'm asking, really, for the
solution to this system,
and sort of in words
-- so that's a good --
a totally typical
error equation.
I think the way to
look at it in words
is, at each step, some new
term, new error is committed,
and what happens to that
error at later steps?
At later steps, that
error committed then
gets multiplied by 1 plus a
delta t at the next step and 1
plus a delta t at
the following step.
So I think we have something
like, after n steps,
we would have 1 plus a delta
t to the n-th times the error
that we did -- our
first step error.
So that's -- you see
what's happening here?
Whatever error we commit
grows or decays according
to this growth factor.
Then of course, we made
an error at step two
and we made an error at
step k, so at step k,
it will have n minus
k steps still to grow.
This is DE, the
error DE at step k,
and all the way through the --
I guess it would end with DE_N.
DE_N would be the last
thing that hadn't yet
started to grow or decay.
Okay.
So that's our formula.
It looks a little messy,
but it shows everything.
It shows the crucial important
of stability and how it enters.
Stability controls -- so there
is the error that we made way
at the beginning and then
this is the growth factor that
happened n time, so you see
that if 1 plus a delta t has
magnitude bigger than 1,
what's going to happen?
That will explode
and the computer
will very quickly show
totally out of bounds output.
But if it's stable, if
this thing is less than 1,
less or equal to 1, then that
stability means that this error
is not growing and so
we get -- so let me put,
if we have this stability,
1 plus a delta t,
smaller equal 1, then we
get the bound that we want.
So can you see what
that looks like?
We've got N terms, right?
To get to point N, we've made
N errors -- capital N errors --
and then each term,
that gives a 1.
That's the critical
role of stability.
And the error is of this order,
so I'm getting something like
a half delta t squared
over 2 times --
let's say some maximum.
I'll use u double prime for
a maximum value, let's say,
of the second derivative.
That's a typical good
satisfactory error estimate.
So what's up here?
So N times delta t --
times one delta t --
is the time that
we reached, right?
We took N steps,
delta t each step.
So this is the same as --
this is what I'm wanting
and it's going to
fit on this board --
there's a one half T -- I
should make it T over 2, right?
N delta t is some time
capital T. We have the half.
We still have one delta t.
That's the key.
We have this u double
prime, which is fixed.
Anyway, we have
first-order convergence.
So the error after n steps
goes down like delta t.
If I cut the time step in
half, I cut the error in half.
So that's not a great
rate of convergence.
That's, like, the minimal
rate of convergence --
just one power delta t.
And that's why we call
Euler a first-order method.
I think, I hope you've seen and
can kind of -- because we'll --
this expression for the solution
is messy but meaningful.
That's a little bit of
pure algebra or something
that shows how stability
is used, where it enters.
So now I'm ready, if you are,
to move to second-order methods.
Now we're actually
going to get methods
that people would really use.
So all those methods are,
I think, worth looking at.
Can I say that the notes
that are on the web --
you may have spotted chapter
five, section one, for example,
which is this material --
so I'm -- after the lecture,
I always think back, what did
I say and improve those notes,
so possibly later this
afternoon a revised,
improved version of this
material will go up and then
next week starts the real thing,
what I think of as the real
thing, the wave equation
and the heat equation --
partial differential
equations -- but it's worth --
here we saw how stability works.
Here we're going to see how
accuracy can be increased
and in different ways.
In this way -- so what do I
notice about the trapezoidal
method?
Sometimes it's called
Crank-Nicolson.
In PDEs, the same idea was
proposed by Crank and Nicolson.
So what's their idea?
Or what's the trapezoidal
idea in the first place?
Basically, we've centered --
we've recentered the method
at what time position?
You can go ahead.
So where -- instead of
Euler, which was, like,
started at time n,
t_n, or backward Euler,
that was sort of focused
on the new time, t_(n+1),
this combination is at time
n plus a half delta t, right?
Somehow we've symmetrized
everything around a half
and the point is that
around the midpoint,
the accuracy jumps up to 2.
Let me try, always,
u prime equal a*u.
So f is a*u.
Then what does this become?
Can I, as you would
have to do in coding it,
separate the implicit part?
This is implicit, of course.
That stands for this: f_(n+1)
means f of the new unknown u
at the new time.
So it's implicit.
So let me bring that
over to the left side,
because it's sort of
part of the unknown.
I'll multiply through by delta
t and I'll take f to be a*u.
So I just want to rewrite
that for our model problem.
So it will be 1 minus a
half, when I bring that over,
minus a delta t over 2 U_(n+1).
Is that what I get, when I
multiply through by delta t
and bring the
implicit part over?
And now I bring the
explicit part to that side,
so it's 1 plus a half
delta t a delta t U_n.
So that's what we actually
solve at every step.
So first of all, I see
that it's pretty centered.
I see that there's something
has to be inverted.
That's because the
method's implicit.
If this was a matrix,
a system of equations,
which is very typical -- could
be a large system of equations
with a matrix, capital A. Then
u would be a vector and we would
be solving this system: matrix
times vector equals known
right-hand side from time n.
But here it's a scalar,
it's just a division,
so what is stability
going to depend on?
What does stability require?
At every step, we
don't want to grow.
So if we take a step -- that's
1 plus a over 2 delta t divided
by 1 minus a over 2 delta
t, that's the growth factor,
the decay factor that multiplies
U_n to give you n plus 1,
so the stability question is,
is this smaller or equal to 1?
That's stability for
this trapezoidal method.
What's the story on that?
Suppose a is very negative.
That's what killed
forward Euler, right?
If a delta t -- that's where
we look for instability.
If a delta t becomes
too negative,
we lost stability
in forward Euler
and we'll lose stability in
other, better methods too.
But here, if a
delta t is negative,
that denominator is good.
It's bigger than the
numerator, right?
So we have a -- you'll see it.
If a delta t is less than 0,
if it's very much less than 0,
then this is approaching maybe
minus 1, but it's below 1.
So this method is A-stable.
Absolutely stable.
Stable for all a less than 0.
We're fine.
Delta t can be, in principle,
as large as we like.
So we might ask, why
don't I just jump
in one step to the time that
I want to reach and not bother
taking a lot of small steps?
What's the -- in
that little paradox?
It would be stable,
but what's no good?
So if I jumped in
one giant step,
this thing would be about
minus 1 or something.
So u here would be
about minus 1 times u_0,
and of course that's
not the answer.
So why do we still
need a delta t?
Because of the
discretization error.
Because this isn't the
exact differential equation,
so we still need -- we don't
have problem with stability,
but we still have to get the
local errors down to whatever
level we want.
Now what are those local
errors for this guy?
What are the local
errors for that method?
Let's see.
Can we actually see it?
I mean, you know what
I'm thinking, right?
I'm thinking that
the local error
is of order delta t cubed.
That's a second-order
method for me.
Delta t cubed at each step.
1 over delta t steps, so
delta t squared overall,
and that's second order.
But do we see why this is?
I mean, instinctively, we say,
it's centered, it should be.
But let me expand
this to see, are we --
is e to the a delta t --
how close is it to 1 --
so it's approximately 1 plus
a over 2 delta t divided by 1
minus a half a delta t.
I just want to see that sure
enough, this is second order.
So of course, I have
a denominator here
that I want to multiply.
So that's 1 plus a delta t
over 2, the explicit part,
and then everybody
knows the 1 --
there are only two series
to know, the truth is.
We study infinite series
a lot, but the two
that everybody needs to know
are the exponential series,
which is for the left side,
and the geometric series,
for the right side, 1
over 1 minus x is 1 plus x
plus x squared plus so on.
So that's the -- this
came from the denominator,
getting it up in the numerator
where I can multiply the other
term and get 1 plus a
delta t, which is good
and what's the coefficient
of a squared delta t squared?
Can you see what it is?
If I do that multiplication,
what does -- you see it?
Where do I get a delta
t squared from this?
I get one here, times 1/4
and I get 1 here times 1/4,
so that's 2/4, is 1/2.
So it's great, right?
It got the next term correct
in the exponential series.
so that's why it's one
order higher, because it
got the right number there, but
it won't get the right number
at the next step.
What's the -- I'd have to
find out what the cube --
this would be a delta t over
2 cubed, so what will it --
the I'll get a wrong
coefficient for a delta t cubed.
I'll get -- that would give
me 1/8 and this would give me
another 1/8, I think, so I think
I'm getting two eighths out
of that.
I'm getting 1/4, which is wrong.
What's right there?
For the exponential
series, it should
be one over three factorial.
It should be 1/6.
So I got 1/4, not
1/6, and the error
is the difference between
them, which is 1/12.
So 1/12 would be this number.
The local error, so
the local error DE
would be like the missing 1/12,
the delta t to the third power
now, and the third derivative.
That's what would come out
if I patiently went through
the estimate, just to
see, because we'll --
in these weeks, we'll be
creating difference methods
for partial differential
equations and we'll want
to know, what's
controlling the error?
This is the kind of calculation,
the beginning of a Taylor
series that answers
that question.
So the main point is, local
error delta t cubed, stable
for every a delta t.
So our method would move from
Euler to trapezoidal and it
would give us a final
error e -- sorry, small e.
I can say it without writing it.
The error, small e, would
be delta t to -- what power?
Squared, delta t squared.
Good.
The same kind of reasoning
-- now I want to ask about --
so that takes care
of trapezoidal,
which is a pretty good method.
I think it's -- in MATLAB, it
would be ode something small t
for trapezoidal.
Forgot -- maybe 1, 2.
I should know.
It's used quite a bit.
Of course, we're going to
get higher than second order,
but second order is often,
in computational mathematics,
a good balance.
Newton's method for
solving nonlinear equation
is second order and it
doesn't pay to go to higher.
You could invent a -- you
could beat Newton by going,
by inventing some third-order
method for solving a nonlinear
equation, but in the end,
Newton would be the favorite.
So second order is
pretty important.
So let me point to --
so that was implicit,
because it involved f_(n+1),
but Adams had another idea,
which seems like a great idea.
Instead of implicit,
using f_(n+1),
he used the previous value,
f_(n-1), which we already know.
We've already, at
that previous step,
substituted u_(n-1) into f.
That might have
been time consuming,
but we sure had to do
it once and we only
have to do it once with Adams.
We're using something
we already know.
This is the one new
time that we need it,
that we have to compute f, and
we get explicitly the new u.
These numbers, 3/2
and minus 1/2 were
chosen to make it second
order and the notes
check that, that with the series
that it comes out to give us
the correct second term.
Good.
Let me mention
backward differences.
Now we're just using one f
and actually the implicit one,
so I'm making it implicit.
So why am I interested
in number 3 at all?
Because it's going to
have better stability.
By being implicit and by
choosing these numbers,
3/2, minus 4/2, and 1/2,
I've upped the accuracy to 2,
p equal to 2, and I've
maintained high stability
by making it implicit.
So this one competes with this
one for importance, for use.
So you're really seeing
three pretty good methods
that can be written down.
So these numbers
were chosen to get
that extra accuracy, which we
didn't get from backward Euler.
When those numbers
were 1 and minus 1,
backward Euler was
only first order.
Now this goes up to second order
and you can guess that we can
-- that every term
we allow ourselves,
we can choose our
coefficients well,
so that the order
goes up by one more.
Now if you looked at that,
you might say, why not keep --
you could come back to this.
Why not combine the idea of
backward differences, more
left-hand sides, with
the Adams-Bashforth idea
of more right-hand sides?
Suppose I come back
to Adams-Bashforth
and create like
an 18.086 method.
That'll be third order,
but still will only
go back one step.
So it will somehow use
some combination like this,
that goes back -- I'm not
writing this method down,
for a good reason, of course,
but it will use something like
this on the left side
and something like this
on the right side and that
gives us enough freedom,
enough coefficients to choose
-- two coefficients there,
three there -- and enough --
that we can get third-order
accuracy.
In other words, the natural idea
is use both U_(n-1) and f_(n-1)
in the formula to get
that extra accuracy.
So why isn't that the
most famous method of all?
Why isn't that
even on the board?
You can guess.
It's violently
unstable, so sadly,
the most accurate methods,
which use both an old value of u
and an old value of f of u,
use both of this and this --
the numbers that show
up here are bad news.
It's a fact of life and so
that's why we go backwards.
We have to make a choice:
We go backwards with u,
or Adams goes backwards with
f, or we think of something way
to hype up the accuracy even
further within one step method.
So the notes give a table,
the beginning of a table.
People could figure out the
formulas for any order p,
so the notes will
give the beginning
of a table for p equal 1,
which is Euler; p equal 2,
which is this; p
equal 3 and p equal 4,
which is Adams-Bashforth
further back, backward
differences further back.
And those tables
show the constants.
So they show the 1/12
or the 1/2 or whatever
that is, and they show
the stability limit
and of course, that's critical.
The stability limit is much
better for backward differences
than it is for Adams-Bashforth.
So actually, I only learned
recently that Adams-Bashforth,
which we all teach, which all
books teach, I should say,
isn't that much used way back --
maybe the astronomers might use
it or they might use
backward differences,
which are more stable.
So backward differences
has an important role
and then one-step methods
will have an important role.
Backward differences
are implicit,
so those are great for stiff
-- you turn that way for stiff
equations and for
nonstiff equations,
let me show you what
the workhorse method is
in a moment.
So I have a number 4 here,
whose name I better put up here.
Let me put up the name
of method 4, which
is two names: Runge-Kutta.
So that's a sort of
one compound step.
So what do I mean by --
what's the point of --
this looked pretty efficient,
but there are two aspects that
we didn't really -- I
didn't really mention,
and on those two aspects,
Runge-Kutta wins by being just
a single self-contained step.
So what are the
drawbacks of a multistep
method like this or like this?
You have to store the
old value, no problem,
but at the beginning, at t
equals 0, what's the problem?
You don't know the old value, so
you have to get started somehow
with some separate -- you
can't use this at t equals 0,
because it's calling for a
value at minus delta t and you
haven't got it.
So you need -- it takes
a separate method.
You can deal with that,
create -- use Runge-Kutta,
for example, to get
that first step.
But then there's another
problem with these backward step
methods, which again,
can be resolved.
So this is a live method.
The other problem is, if you
want to change delta t --
suppose you want to
cut delta t in half,
then this is looking for a
value that's a half delta t back
in time and you haven't
got that either,
but you've got values 1 delta
t back and 2 delta t back
and some interpolation process
will produce that half value.
So what am I saying?
I'm just saying
that getting started
takes a special
attention, changing
delta t takes a little
special attention,
but still, it's all doable.
So that this method, which I
gave a name to last time --
I've forgotten what it was.
I think it was
something like ode15s
for stiff is much used
for stiff equations.
So now I'm left -- let
me not only write down
Runge-Kutta's name,
but the other --
so multistep I've spoken about.
I just -- this is -- I'm just
going to write this to remind
myself to say one
word about it -- DAE.
Can I say one word even now?
I'm sorry.
Then I'll say one word later.
So that's a differential
algebraic equation.
That's like a situation
which comes up
in chemical engineering and
many other places, in which,
out of our n given
equations, some of them
are differential
equations, but others
are ordinary algebra equations,
so there's no d by dt in them.
Nevertheless, we have to
solve, and there is a d by dt
in the others.
So this is a whole
little world of DAEs,
which you may never meet.
I have never personally met.
But it has to be dealt
with and there are codes --
I'll just mention the
code DASSL by Petzold --
I'll finish saying the one word.
A model problem here
would be some matrix times
u prime equal f of u and t, so
a sort of implicit differential
equation, because I'm
not given u prime,
I'm only given M u prime.
If M is singular -- otherwise
I could multiply by M inverse
and make it totally normal,
but if M, at some times t --
or M may depend on u and
t -- it could go singular.
If it goes singular, then
this system is degenerating
and we have to think what to do.
And this DASSL code would be
one of the good ones that does.
So that's sort of like
my memory to myself
to say something about
DAEs before completing
this topic of ordinary
differential equations.
Now for Runge-Kutta.
Let me take p equal to 2 first.
The famous Runge-Kutta
is the one at p equal --
with forth order accuracy.
That will take more of the
little internal compounded
steps than p equal
to 2 takes, but p
equal to 2 makes the point.
So this'll be simplified
Runge-Kutta -- p equal to 2.
It'll be U_(n+1) minus U_n --
you see, it's just one step,
but what goes here?
Do I remember?
The notes will tell me.
I better -- since it's
going to be kept forever,
I better get it right.
It involves f_n and f of f,
so Runge-Kutta, here we go.
It has a half of f_n, the usual
Euler figure out this slope.
But then, the other half is
the same f at -- I take Euler,
so doing this part allowed me
to take a forward Euler step,
and now I put that forward Euler
step in as like a U_(n+1) delta
t f_n at time --
what's the right time?
Probably -- that's sort of
-- this is like u_(n+1),
but we didn't have to do --
we're not implicit and so I
presume that that's
at time n plus 1.
So I've written in one
line what the code would
have to write in two lines.
The first line of code would
be compute f at the old U_n,
then take an Euler step,
multiply it by delta t and add
to U_n, so this gives
something that's like U_(n+1),
but didn't cost us anything.
So can you compare
that with trapezoidal?
You see, the comparison with
trapezoidal is trapezoidal has
the 1/2 f_n, the same, but it
has the 1/2 f_(n+1) at the new
step, involving the new U_(n+1),
where this one is something
like it, but something we
already knew from Euler.
So that's the natural idea.
All these ideas actually
would occur to all of us,
if we started thinking
about these for a few weeks.
But, I guess I'm not planning
to spend a few weeks on that,
so I'm just jumping ahead to
what people have thought of.
So that's, you could
say, two-step Euler.
There's two evaluations
of f within a step.
So what's p equal 4?
The famous Runge-Kutta
is four of those.
So you take --
there's an Euler step.
That'll be step one.
Then you'll stick that into
something, at step n plus 1/2.
That'll be a second
evaluation of f.
That'll give you some output.
You plug that in and
that will actually,
if it's correctly chosen, be
another, better approximation
at 1/2, at n plus 1/2.
You put that into
the fourth one,
which will give you something
close to U_(n+1) and then you
take the right weights.
Here they were 1/2 and 1/2.
Anyway, you can do it.
The algebra begins to get
messy beyond p equal 4,
but you can go beyond p equal 4.
I mean, there's books
on Runge-Kutta methods
because the algebra gets
-- of these f of f of f.
If there's anything that -- any
construction in math that looks
so easy, just take f of f
of f of f of a function,
of a number.
That seems so simple, but
actually it's extremely hard
to understand what happens.
Maybe you know that Mandelbrot's
fractal sets and all
these problems of chaos
come exactly that way
and they're extremely hard
to see what's happening.
When you do repeated
composition,
you would call that f of f of f.
So Runge-Kutta stops
at 4 and then there
is actually an
implicit Runge-Kutta
that people work
on, but I don't dare
to begin to write that
down and I won't even
write the details of that
one, which are in our notes
and in every set of notes.
But what's the point?
First, we get the
accuracy, so what's
the other thing you
have to ask about?
Stability.
So what does our
stability calculation
give for Runge-Kutta?
The thing that you
have to work with,
actually, turns out
to be quite nice.
It's just the series for
e to the a*t chopped off
at the power, however
far you're going.
So this is Runge-Kutta
stability, p equal to 2.
The growth factor
will be from --
if I just do this and I take
the model problem, f equal a*u,
you could -- if I took
that out of there,
the growth factor will be 1 plus
a delta t plus 1/2 a delta t
squared.
Stop.
That's what this would
give, for the model problem,
as the growth factor that
multiplies each U to get
the next U. What p equal 4 would
give would be the same thing
plus -- it's just the right
-- it's just the exponential
series chopped off
at the fourth term.
So of course, you
see immediately,
what's the discretization error?
It's delta t of the fifth.
It's the first missing term
that Runge-Kutta didn't capture,
multiplied by 1
over 5 factorial,
so you know right away that
the constant is 1 over 120,
which is pretty good.
But the question
is the stability.
So what do we want to know here?
We want to know -- so let
me let a delta t be some --
because that same number is
coming up -- let me call it z,
right?
So the stability test,
for p equal to 2,
is to look at the
magnitude of 1 plus z
plus 1/2 z squared and we
want it to be less than
or equal to 1.
Now, the point is,
this is something --
I hope you try
this this weekend.
Somehow get MATLAB to plot,
in the complex plane --
see you really -- up there now
we've just -- at some point z,
some negative value of z -- it's
going to hit 1 and then after
that, it's going to be unstable.
Of course, there's got to be
a point where it's unstable.
This is an explicit method.
Runge-Kutta is explicit.
So it can't -- if the
problem is too stiff,
we're going to be killed, but
if it's an ordinary problem,
this is a winner.
So p equal 4, this is the
code ode45, which uses --
combines Runge-Kutta with 4 on
a higher-order formula to get
an estimate for the
error in that step.
So I could make some comment
on predictor-corrector methods,
but I'll leave
that in the notes.
So, what does that
region look like?
And then, the other one is, what
does the region 1 plus the z
plus 1/2 z squared plus
1/6 z cubed plus 1/24 z
to the fourth,
less or equal 1 --
what's that region look like?
I mean, if those regions
are small, the method loses.
If those regions
are bigger than we
get from Adams-Bashforth
or backward differences,
then the methods in there
are good, successful.
I've forgotten exactly what
the picture is like there.
Why am I in the complex plane?
Because the number
a -- z is a delta t.
That number a can be complex.
How can it be complex?
I'm not really thinking that
our model equation u prime equal
a*u will be complex, but our
model system would be u prime
equals a matrix times u and then
it's the eigenvalues of that
matrix that take the
place of little a.
So we have n different
little a's going for a system
and the eigenvalues of a totally
real matrix can be nonreal,
can be complex numbers.
Let's just think when that
happens and then I'll --
what does the figure looks like?
For p equals 4, I sort of
remember that the figure even
captures a little bit of that
plane and then it goes --
why should I mess
up the board with --
it's a pretty good-sized region.
It's probably not
shaped like that at all,
but the point is, maybe
this reaches out to about e,
minus e.
I think it does,
somewhere around --
I don't know if that's
an accurate -- right,
reaches out around minus --
and reaches up to around 2.
So in this last second, I
was just going to say --
and we'll see it plenty of times
-- where do we get complex --
where do we get nice,
real, big systems,
stiff systems with complex
eigenvalues in real
calculations?
By real calculations,
I really mean PDEs.
So in a partial
differential equation --
so this is just a throw-away
comment that we'll deal with
again -- in partial
differential equations,
a u_(x,x) term or a u_(y,y)
term -- that get multiplied,
typically, by diffusion,
those are diffusion terms --
those produce symmetric things,
symmetric negative definite.
But convection, advection
terms, velocity terms that get
multiplied by some -- that
are first derivatives --
those produce -- those
are antisymmetric.
Those produce these
complex eigenvalues
that we have to deal with.
So, everybody wants to
solve convection-diffusion.
Convection has these
terms, diffusion has these.
The coefficient
may be very small.
The hard -- that's
the hard case,
when the convection is serious.
It's pushing us up
the imaginary axis,
where this is bringing
us to the left
and we're going to spend
time thinking of good methods
for that.
So my homework -- would you like
figure out this region and make
a better pictures?
Get MATLAB to do it and try
any one of these methods
on the model problem.
Try a method or two.
See whether the stability, the
theoretical stability limit
is serious.
I mean, does the limit
of a delta t -- can we --
as I'm driving to MIT, I
sometimes exceed the speed
limit, the stability limit.
Is that OK or not with
finite differences?
I'll see you Monday.
All right, thanks.
Have a good weekend.